cette telle taquin d'embrun oui pour un
domaine tu réponds
non
elle c'était la grogne
il
grogne
il promenait sa bonhomie bras ballants
vos mains dans les poches et sont avides
de bons amis suivaient ton dissonant les
cloches sans rythme elle le cam nul est
à grommelé des arguties il répond d'être
d'école lead il ripostait par des lasi
le tag faisait des niches et la grogne
on vous connaît la grenouille et éboué
le taquin sont un peu le tac a faisait
des niches et la rognon bogota la grogne
ont été beaucoup mais lucho tous sont
tamponnés assesseurs il était poète qui
lui causait de papillons chute elle
avait mal à la tête je faisais la
télévision petite-terre études dont vous
voyons tu n'es plus un gamin à ce que
toi donc pendant sept ans et suit tes
pieds prend les patins
le tas gaffeur et dénis et la croyons
pour mener la grogne on est et bulut a
que sont un peu le tagueur faisait 10 et
la grogne on connaît la grogne on a été
grand mais le toquin sont en poney mais
le texte en poney mais le cac 1 100
abonnés
il siffle et perles de cristal pendant
qu'elle mangeait des cachets il
s'écriait t'as vu l'étoile et répondait
mettons cache nez elle ne planait jamais
plus haut que le plus hot ses bigoudis
et lui allongé sur le dos réveille de
mille et une nuits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était la grogne ans
ton sourire
oui toujours bien
lui c'était le taquin le paka faisait
déni et la grande boucle ne l'éloignent
ont aidé bongo loue taquin sont un peu
taquin tenir
prenons tous venaient les renault était
bon mais nous taquin sont tamponnés le
texte définit et la grenouille ont
boycotté les rognons
thébaux mais le cas qu'un sont un peu le
trac à feu des niches et la grogne en
bourgogne
je connais pas
ga le tango c'est très beau mais on sait
pas les bas fonds mouillé au likès
orchestra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on c'est à la java le chacha connaît pas
compter
dougan
le temps de ces très beaux me on sait
palier pas pour mouiller
ça fait
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
ils attendent un seul pas aussi patronat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'écoute le haut on agite le bas ses
plus beaux
bayonne ça fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore
ana
peut-être
sa fille et moi c'est plus vrai que ce
cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le trou
le pas
mais sans passer ça part et ça vaut la
samba dans son solo
tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
hahaha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sympa
le sens pas plus swing jazz
sans moi si ça y'a papa
théorie c'est moi gaulliste
gfr
plus vieux qu'elle saint-tropez
[Musique]
non plus
c'est le sens pas
sans passé sans pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'est pas à cause d'eux
toki guéri
mambo maladie
après tout petit
le haut du là
des cas comme
[Musique]
avi
oh
monde
ou pas
oui
plus de sous
mais cette rencontre
et jusqu'à 3
c'est bien
tous en coulisses
m
[Musique]
du jeu
tu sais
la manie des cargos
argent
les gabarits
touba
nathan
bourque
josé
la bbc
pour les plus jeunes à ses jours
un bon
le cas
[Musique]
jour levante jeu
c'est
je
et
[Musique]
ils attendent
la vanille
les gâteaux
mam
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
comme annie
t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
être aujourd'hui beaucoup moi être sans
doute affronter six cartes
j'ai dit je re avait-on dit partout je
déserte où les armes avec un camion
lourd je pouvoir aimer vos brebis
philippe husser les yeux comme un hibou
concevoir pour j'ai loupé le matin
me thibault je devenir des accords
juridiques mon coeur faire la musique
pour faire la musique du tout
non
mon corps faire la musique du tarn
faux
vous voyez moi dans le court il me dit
je donne des fleurs à bout
[Musique]
voir le loup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je mariez-vous cannibales et mangez moi
et j'ai dévoré vous être joli
mais se faire croquer mon monsieur
moyenne gamme
gérard cagna
[Musique]
tant qu'animaux midi jeux chouchouter
secret okami sur rodez ou courir dans la
nature à donner pour toi les canons dca
libye pour vous je me bats pour mes vous
pas prêt mais vous excessif
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
les gens quittent et yuki où il était le
gentil petit il était où 1
ils étaient où l'une était le gentil
c'est qui cette affaire
s'ils étaient ou sont pas pareils plus
pop et électro qui préfèrent et sa mère
alors que sa mère l'a même la mouche
elle était où un amer qui veut tout ce
qui fait qu'avec la mouche il est sinon
le loup gris il était 8e
[Musique]
qui aujourd'hui disent il était où
rousset qui les fait sont pas poussées
sont à faire on sait qu'un petit poucet
qu'il n'était pas pu
[Musique]
temps s'il était là le bouzouki
pitchouns il était là le plus beau des
cookies il était là qui le populo le
plus joli de tous les boutons été
acquise aux articles 6 et lé papadopoli
et la cucm été accueilli la docteure
gobbi et le youki à l'heure et les
acquis à tous et il a maintenant pignon
qu'est ce qui le porte à son papy au
canon qui le dit
c
mais l'outil les gens du peuple c'était
pas me font pas peur alors qu'il était
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent à houla le
bilan
tu as mangé beaucoup de sacs à dos
d'éléphant et l'entravé novethic grande
écoute on est pas couché à vous de vous
coucher
le méchant
coucou suisse ont fait perdre à fâcher
c'est un goût amer est en colère le père
ayew coupé beaucoup bavé si bien le pli
du sud cette équipe mais qui sait
de nous cette équipe ce qui fait qu'il
faut que tu déconnes
et c'était pas ton papier le plus
coûteux alors ce qu'il veut te avait
tout son tapis pour s'imposer
[Musique]
de toute façon c'était pas le youki et
qui fêtait pas tout à fait le plus dur
de toute façon ce n'étaient pas les
outils et des faits de pâte en habit le
plus que tu vas voir ce qui lui donne
elle avait quitté son papy dit la
famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
toujours en quête d'une paix
ils ont mis en cause
les commandes de longue date est
tellement c'est tout cela a tout le
temps à l'époque pas si vite
il ya des fois où ça
ratha dire que les estime à son piteux
pts 10
if we et n'ont peut-être pas paul dit
simplement je constate
[Musique]
extrait de qom
selon cette assurance est pas à 100%
mais quand même
enfin deux satellites ont tout pouvoir
les montre pas forcément
les faibles les mirettes toujours mais
souvent faute
[Musique]
les landais
et
les cochonnets
non
mais je sais
sur les mains
les groupes constrictor
les messieurs climat tout elle adore ça
lui
encana tout hollywood est difficile
foppa catalogue
[Musique]
dames
une aide à rouler
marc et leur tour le bail ou se laissent
pousser les toiles d'araignées
détails
[Musique]
on connaît de sacrifier faits qui ont
pris ce risque des deux côtés
cette historienne
en gros a priori dans toute affaire le
myope
on suppose au départ une salle le
suppute
faudrait pas signer tout ne pense pas
qu'à ça tout ça c'est un bandit
pourquoi donc sont elles si réputé
[Musique]
il n'est que
nous on paye peut-être des idées
m
pour bien faire fondre les essayer
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soir je suis tout seul sur le mach en
braille
dans ma tête je lui dis nous deux
or
et
surgie d'un gîte partout
la ligue 1
[Musique]
m
où
les valises sous les yeux
entre les exams toujours à la
un peu
forte j'ai maintenant un placard
comme une hollandaise
il
qui lui
dans l'euphorie générale avait sa salade
était compétent
et vous
presque 2
le score
j'ai bon
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
entrant banias
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les fondamentaux
epages jeudis en chansons
afri fauchant
je vais
le plein
montre en main doublure pour faire peur
au final
les grenats
à gauche les groupies
dizzy gillespie pomme
m
je tiens tiens
oui
[Musique]
pensez y penser
à
[Applaudissements]
un jour sans aucun doute
vous aviez
une fille mais je serais sûrement
mais la mairie
ea com
pour fermer tibet
m
et je peux pas monter j
à la carte
hélas pas impressionner
ça
attention les yeux j'ai lu
[Musique]